welcome back to the show that today
features a match-up of such
extraordinary talent i'm
sure it's going to be enjoyed by humans
superhumans
humans who dress as bats talking owls
and of course
light beer-swilling robots yep it's a
vigorous vault into two vivacious visual
visionaries
whose films have run the gamut from
victorious to vexing
how in the name of zeus's butthole
sure we've had directorial matchups
before but not even the might of a
christopher nolan
or the box office success of a james
cameron could compete
with the sheer amount of times you've
seen these two monikers trending on
social media
zack snyder and michael bay the mayor
mentioned a bay or snyder in a public
forum of any
kind could spark such a backlash it
would feel akin to breaking into a
maximum security prison
well then consider me stanley goodspeed
because we're going to find out who has
the chops
the eye the ability to do that super
condescending director framing thing
with their fingers the best
in one corner it's the explosive action
and slo-mo
billowing close of michael bay in the
other it's the elaborate
cuts and attention to detail of zack
snyder a universe of hashtags await with
baited breath as we determine the best
instigator of internet idol tree
of all time here's how we'll determine a
winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash
audience score round three iconic
characters
round four memorable moments and then
we'll do a wild card round that
shouldn't but
probably will involve popular mom first
names
thankfully there's no four-hour cut of
this show i don't care i don't get paid
by the hour do i
do i get paid at all well honestly i
don't care i'm just happy
to praise sucker punch yes really
i like the movie let's get it on
autobots
we charge together spa tags
what is your profession
round one box office unlike me i'll tell
you who does get paid
movie studios when these two fellas
release a new talking picture
doesn't matter what the social media
buzz is or how many secret cuts of a
film might exist
audiences show up in droves to see a new
bay or snyder picture
as any exec will tell you during their
lunch at the ivy
these flicks cost a pretty penny to make
but man are they worth it
especially when they involve those
transforming cyborgs
what are those things transformers
that's right
michael bay's most popular franchise
based on my favorite toys
not named he-man may have been some of
his biggest hits
and boasts three films that cross the
billion dollar mark at the worldwide box
office
when we adjust for inflation the
ultimate breadwinner was transformers
dark of the moon or
t3 for short age of extinction and
revenge of the fallen
also broke that seal as did michael
bay's 1998
scientifically accurate armageddon
what's up here did nasa fighting oil on
your anus man
all told bay is currently considered the
fifth highest grossing director
ever across the globe as his films have
done a total
of 6.4 billion dollars if we don't
adjust for inflation
but if we did i'm guessing it's higher
dude's average per movie is a staggering
495 million bucks over 14 movies
in fact he's only ever had two films not
gross at least 100 million dollars on
planet earth
pain and gain and 13 hours fun fact
you'll hear me recite throughout this
episode
i love 13 hours
love it that's what i'm telling you but
now zack snyder's got something to say
as one of the captains of the dceu do we
still call it the
ship since his man of steel movie came
out in 2013
he knows a thing or nine about making
some cheddar he's been
tantalizingly close to the billion
dollar mark falling
just short when batman v superman dawn
of justice
earned 950 million dollars in all
countries
however he's never had a film do less
than 100 million dollars at the adjusted
global cineplex
sucker punch just made the cut at 104
million dollars
i'm responsible for 4 million of those
dollars his inaugural directorial effort
dawn of the dead made 154 million bucks
and then swoop in the owls of gahool at
165 million dollars
fun fact you'll hear me recite
throughout this episode i love
legends of the guardians love it come on
unfortunately for zach not even the
might of dc's greatest heroes can topple
all of the autobot
decepticon and buzz aldrin appearances
from the transformers franchise
snyder's total haul over his career the
world over is 3.1 billion dollars
making for a stellar average of 396
million per flick
plus all those hbo max subscriptions his
cut of justice league reeled in
the numbers tighten up when we consider
just the domestic box office as only 14
million dollars separates bay's
179 million dollar per film average from
snyder's 165 million dollar
usual take i say only 14 million because
for these guys that barely covers the
cost of craft services for a week
have you seen how much lobster megatron
can put away
round one goes the way of bay a fella
who has his own street named after him
on the paramount lot
the transformers bad boys and 13 hours
franchises were just
too much for zack snyder even though 13
hours was
just one movie it's a franchise in my
household
bay one snyder zilch
[Applause]
you're wonderful you're wonderful round
two tomato meter slash audience score
remember all that cheddar the
transformers raked in to help michael
bay win round one
yeah that might be his achilles heel in
this round because critics
aren't quite as favorable to them but
wait hang on
the first transformers live action movie
is at a 58
on the tomato meter that's almost fresh
that's cool
look out zack snyder here comes michael
bay and the
ah from there it was all downhill
revenge of the fallen didn't rebound and
fell to 20
age of extinction set the new low mark
at 17
and then transformers the last night
said hold my product placement beer
and notch just 15 yikes [ __ ] get out of
my way
move [ __ ] get out of my way okay but
zack snyder's had some smelly eggs laid
too
just ask oh no is it it's sucker punch
despite my affinity for that fantastical
led zeppelin music video sequence
it's his lowest moment on the tomato
meter checking in
at just 22 percent batman v superman is
also low
at 28 percent and justice league i'm
hoping for four hour filet mignon from
mr snyder
okay okay we get it sometimes critics
may not dig the art these guys have
crafted
but come on they both made fresh films
too right
michael bay has the rock which welcomed
him to fresh town at 66 percent
see and he also has that's
it what pain and gain flirted with
ripeness but landed at 50
and bad boys is at 42 percent the door
is wide open for snyder and the owls of
gut
they're rotten the owl movie is run it's
at 52
okay but he does have dawn of the dead
300 abs and watchmen all
safely on the pleasant side of fresh and
looking at these scores
dawn of the dead and it's 75 looks like
citizen
i kane this song so while zach's tomato
meter average is a respectable 50
to mikey's predictable 37 these dudes
crank out movies for fans
just like the ones who weigh in on the
audience score
where we totally kinda redeem ourselves
a little bit
both directors enjoy fresh averages here
bay even has three films cracking eighty
percent
on the audience score metric
transformers at eighty-five percent
really okay i'm just asking the rock at
the same lofty number 85
and then 13 hours at 82 percent you're
welcome
zack snyder takes the ultimate audience
score prize with an 89
for 300. in fact his only rotten output
here is
regrettably once again sucker punch am i
just backing the wrong movies here
is it me am i
on the strength of his early work like
300 dawn of the dead and watchmen
zack snyder's audience score average per
film is a bill and ted excellent 69
percent
michael bay trails them by only three at
66 percent
but close only counts in horseshoes and
hand grenades and if you've ever seen a
bayer snyder film
you know grenades very well zack snyder
wins the round
gets on the board and ties it up at one
a piece
[Music]
round three iconic character zack snyder
is feeling warm and could be piping hot
after a round that rewards beloved
all-time characters
the guy makes cinema with batman wonder
woman the definitely not
mustached boy from kansas how can he
lose it around
called iconic characters well ever hear
of optimus
prime bumblebee iceberg oh wait iceberg
was a g.i joe
have we done that crosstalk we should
okay but you get the point
not impressed so i think it's only fair
to acknowledge the legacy of the
characters that these dudes didn't
create
but to weigh this round a tad heavier on
the original heroes and villains they
did give us
michael bay built up an impressive
resume in the 1990s alone
he gave us the bad boys mike and marcus
in 1995
and the chemistry exhibited by will
smith and martin lawrence still rang
true
through last year's bad boys for life
which they produced you can fight
oh you move [ __ ] you can't fight
and whether you need to break into
then out of a prison or blow up an
asteroid hurling towards earth it was
michael bay
who not only gave us great leads like
nicholas cage's stanley goodspeed
and bruce willis's harry which is
ironically named for him
oh gee whiz we were blessed with
memorable ensembles
who didn't want a pep talk from sean
connery's mason and who didn't well up
when liv tyler's grace
didn't want to miss a thing we may have
not felt the same quite level of
emotional attachment to early zack
snyder characters like baby doll and
blue jones but if we rewind the clock
back a tad earlier snyder can make us
care about
regular humans especially when they're
battling the scariest form of undead
creature
ever to roam earth mall zombies sarah
paulie is perfect as anna
as is ving rhames as kenneth and i'll go
ahead and say that leonidas and xerxes
were
at least based on the mythology of real
human beings
and what 300 may lack in character
development it more than made up for
with ab roller sales which has to count
for something
but as we've seen evidence of already
today these gents do their best deep
diving of character creation
when it comes to humongous properties
we've already been familiar with for
decades
for michael bay however it came at a
human cost
does anyone root for people in the
transformers movies
like i get the first one was cool and
back then we might have been somewhat
engaged in the fate of michaela barnes
sam with whitkey and wiki's parents
house
but the gripe i most often hear about
that franchise is that we just want to
see the cyborgs duke it out and leave
humanity on the sidelines
so yes i did care about optimus prime
deeply and i cheered heartily against
megatron
even though i do love him as a villain i
can chalk much of that up to my
childhood bias
walking into the theater but once i sat
down and finished my second batch of
large corn
i really didn't find too many of the
newer robotic rolls
all that interesting or necessary in the
case of revenge of the fallen
some of the transformers were just
downright offensive meanwhile zack
snyder appeared to have an easy task on
his hands as he entered the fray of
comic book film adaptations
after all who wouldn't want to give a
rip about superman batman or the dawn of
wonder woman
he already proved that his characters
would remain faithful to their
hand-drawn roots with his
watchmen carla gagino's sally jupiter
and jackie earl haley's rorschach
are just two of the fully fleshed out
performances we see is it as good as the
hbo series
ah no but fans continue to pine for more
of his take on man of steel
as henry cavill superman brought a true
human emotional spectrum
to the alien from that planet that blew
up i'm so sorry
i should be more sensitive to clark and
his homeworld of melmac
similarly amy adams is lois lane is far
from just a damsel in distress
she's an intrepid reporter that can
throttle a plot forward from the far
ends of the earth
or if she's just chilling in the bathtub
having one of those we need to talk
about us
chats do i have an issue with characters
being named martha
not necessarily although i was not a fan
of the execution of a certain scene
involving their names being dropped but
that's not this round
batman v superman brought another level
of depth to cowell
and showcased a side of bruce wayne you
want to hit
his secret alter ego it's in the title
of the movie that hadn't been previously
explored on the big screen
his shepherding of his own planet ben
affleck stepped into the very hard to
pee and bat suit
and we met a hero who is no longer just
gotham's protector
he was earth's avenger oh no do i get
fined for cross
universe penalty michael bay has given
himself more opportunities over a longer
career to develop characters we truly
care about
but for every home run like the soldiers
of 13 hours he also has strikeouts like
pain and gain
it might be a sort of ridiculous true
story but i've seen that flick several
times and i still can't figure out
are we supposed to laugh cry root for
someone or just sit back and watch it
like tiger king
remember tiger king even by inheriting
characters we've already been fans of
for decades
zack snyder introduced us to a new depth
with them it's not an easy task after
all this time and when someone can pull
it off
it bonds our attachment with them even
tighter plus the guy made me cry
multiple times watching talking owls
solve problems
go watch gahool and demand the four-hour
cut of that movie
zack snyder wins the round and takes a
2-1 lead over michael bay
this is sparta
round four memorable moments say what
you want about this frenzied
action-loving pair but one could argue
there isn't a two-director set that have
given us more thrills over the last 30
years michael bay's work in the 1990s
alone certified him
as one of the most bankable action
directors on the market
largely because he seemed to possess
every tool in the kit
he could make us laugh and shudder with
an opening sequence like the clan rally
in bad boys 2
or he could well us up with emotion when
bruce willis does the old switcheroo on
ben affleck in armageddon
but perhaps his best quality is wedging
a car chase
into any page of a script he wants just
because he feels
like it witness the rock did we need to
wreck all of san francisco for what
amounts to a largely meaningless
sequence
yes yes we did okay
zack snyder eschewed car chases for full
movies that felt like one
long memorable moment like the epic
battle sequences in 300
or the lush music driven fantasy sets in
sucker punch
that flick should have won every mtv
movie award category that year
his action acumen runs so deep it bleeds
into horror territory
as we see that mesmerizing overhead shot
of the zombie horde in dawn of the dead
and one could be forgiven in assuming
his watchmen or dc movies are just fever
dreams brought about by reading too many
comics
snyder famously makes every effort to
stay loyal to the original panels
michael bay takes um a few more
liberties in adapting the transformers
from their animated source material
but the results are just as satisfying
as any time i got my toys out to play
with them when i was a kid
or last week or this morning
it could be the climactic battle in
mission city in the first film
revenge of the fallen's monstrous
explosion near the pyramids
or all of chicago feeling the brunt of
dark of the moon
the full-on robot combat of each and
every transformers film
makes all the wading through the human
direct worth it
even you extinction but barely and call
me a loser you probably already have
but seeing transformers battle during
arthurian times in the last night
that's high school history i can stay
awake for and i'm not gonna penalize
zack snyder for the martha thing during
the moment of truth and dawn of justice
it's true didn't buy it then still don't
buy it
probably never will but i know there's a
contingent of rational folks who do
i've heard your impassioned arguments it
just didn't cut the mustard for moi
but i will give mucho points for the
action surrounding that mommy misfire
and directly after batman crashing in to
save martha
not his mom she was already the other
one and knocking pulls out is flawless
execution in the world of filmmaking
in the literal sense of the word them
baddies were not surviving
that night my favorite all-time snyder
moment is shockingly
not in the owl movie it's at the
beginning of batman v superman where
batman's alter ego discovers
he's gonna have to the superman while
every other sane person is running away
from the
zod battle at the end of man of steel
another great sequence by
the way bruce wayne comes charging
towards it
in that one instance we see what
separates a hero from an
ordinary citizen and the realization
that ben affleck
had to drop all of his dunkin donuts to
run into the rubble ups the ante
even more all that being said
michael bade did the unthinkable with 13
hours i already knew superman and
optimus prime would deliver on amazing
moments
i wasn't prepared for john krasinski the
action star
it's a credit to his performance sure
but also to bay's ability to put his
character jack silva
in the right situations to maximize that
potential
in one super tense car ride jon goes
from being jim who likes pam
to jack frickin ryan 13 hours doesn't
relent from there and provides
gut-wrenching heart-pounding thrills the
likes of which
only exist in the most finely crafted
war cinema
it's moments like that where we remember
why after the rock
michael bay could stand shoulder to
shoulder with tony scott after top gun
john mctiernan after die hard and
kathryn bigelow after point break
he simply gets action and as much as we
might roll our eyes at another
billowing trench coat or lipstick
sipping a pepsi in an extra slow-mo
his movies have given our eyes ears and
bodily functions
as many memorable moments as anyone in
the last three decades
bay sneaks by snyder in round four and
we're all tied up at two apiece
now step back to nap this next mess
knows hey
dude you gotta learn the words we
usually only do the chorus and now it's
time for the wild card round
the highlander conundrum let me explain
myself
no neither one of these guys have
directed a highlander film
yet but we would all bust blocks lining
up to see that movie if they did
right so instead of making this deciding
round about owls versus autobots
i have the owls there or harry stampers
drilling team versus superman
uh yeah you're gonna be missing a whole
lot of things after that loss bruno
i decided to postulate the dilemma of to
quote highlander
there can be only one so let's say i
take you to a movie theater you're
welcome it's fun to hang with
celebrities
and give you a few bucks for a ticket
and some popcorn and now
you have two options walk into the house
showing a new michael bay flick
or head into the next show time for zack
snyder's latest effort
you have no idea what the movies are or
who is starring in them or how long
they'll last
you go in blind with only one director
to trust and that director would be
i can make a great case for zack snyder
because chances are you're seeing a film
that covers some sort of territory with
which you're familiar
could be another dc property another
watchman epic or fingers crossed
another adventure with talking owls or
maybe it's that revolutionary war period
piece filmed 300 style that he hinted at
making years ago
but here's where you can bank on for
certain an all-immersive cinematic feast
for
every one of your senses visuals you
never thought possible set to perfectly
balanced music
with at least a dash of emotional
investment i don't really care if i get
more flying creatures
famous superheroes or zombies that would
dominate at the nfl combine
whatever i get i know it's worth the
price of admission
isn't that right
batman michael bay's movie is guaranteed
to have action
and much of that action will be imax
quality good times
involving nutcase angles raging from
well below the sewer
to the top of a dinobots head i'm going
to be hoping against hope
wish against wish that bay fully commits
to telling a story
solely about humans battling for
survival think the rock are 13 hours
if it is another robot movie just make
it robots
look i want mindless action with just
enough heart to keep me invested while
my bladder screams at me
for getting that double xl sprite
but unfortunately for michael bay the
risk is just too great that cool
explosions are all i get
i've been burned by too many great
trailers for awful transformers movies
sure they have tons of fun moments but
the constant repetition of those without
anything to ground them to an emotional
bedrock becomes
tiresome and unless it's will and martin
and joey pants's painful attempt at a
jump shot
i'm probably not giggling nearly as much
as michael bay
thinks i am displaying finesse and
subtlety
and achieving a goal conversely with
zack snyder i know i may not like every
moment
and some sequences may feel too long or
unnecessary
but i know i get a film made by a
director who ate drank slept
and breathed this material he makes
movies with his entire soul
michael bay can have a tendency to make
me feel like
he thinks i'm either here just for fiery
car chases or to find out which six-pack
to buy on the way home
worse yet he might assume i'm kind of
stupid not that he'd be all that far off
on that one
but i crave a director who sank
everything they had into a project
that they did this for their very soul
not just a paycheck let's talk about
them at their best
michael bay is arguably just as good and
maybe a bit tighter of a filmmaker
than the extravagance-leaning zack
snyder but even with the snyder films
that featured disappointing moments
weak characters or felt too attached to
the source material
i'm gonna get invested i'm not gonna be
wondering about what michael bay movie
i'm missing next door
actually now they think about it let's
screen their movies on opposite ends of
the multiplex
i don't want to hear shia screaming
optimus for the umpteenth time during
sucker punch 3.
zack snyder is my highlander one we're
going to see his movie
and he wins the round
it's three to two zack which means zack
snyder wins
down goes michael bay but in all
fairness i gotta give bae his props the
rock
was so good when a gaggle of me and my
friend saw it opening night
we all broke our respective curfews to
see it all the way to the end
it might be the greatest action film of
the 90s and worth having my phone
privileges taken away for three weeks
transformers could be the most bankable
franchise of the 2000s and
13 hours should have won every oscar it
was nominated for
plus best picture it's not a nutcase
statement to say bay
ceiling is as high or maybe even higher
than zack snyder but today zack snyder
won with his passion for storytelling
and his commitment to see his singular
vision through to the bitter end
but i'm just one man here i'm no
superhero i was never even a lifeguard
at the pool
i'm just a big movie fan and now it's
your turn
let us know on social media whose
library of excessive explosions and
prime protagonists you prefer
i'm mark ellis and i did my best
sorry sean connery i'm not allowed to
say the rest of
that line